everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm today we are in around
seven of our coverage the 2017 US Chess
Championships our competitors today
White's played by yellow slob janabu
ukrainian-born american grandmaster
currently lives in st. louis missouri so
just down the street from where the
tournaments at he's 23 years old has a
rating of 26:57 his opponent Fabiana
Caruana playing the black piece is 24
years old also lives in st. Louis
Missouri so they're somewhat neighbors
with the current rating of 28 66 third
highest rated player in the world does
have a 200 points difference in rating
from Fabiano and yellow Slav both of
these players are tied for second only a
half a point coming into this round
behind Wesley so and before this game
ended Wesley so tied his game so if only
these players can get a victory they
will be tied for the lead we'll go ahead
and get started with the other saw
starting with pawn to e4 punny 5 and
Knight f3 knight c6 and then Bishop to
b5 so getting into the Rui Lopez pawn to
a6 push it back here to a4 a nice f6
we've been seeing a lot of this castle
on the Kings side this should be seven
and we see a very interesting variation
the right Lopez haven't seen it all too
often it has crept up every now and then
and that is the Brier variation if
you're not super familiar with it after
the bishop comes back here to b3 pawn d6
just a little flying Ponce e3 getting
ready to push forward with pawn to d4
castle on the kingside pawn age 3 and
the knight to be Aiden this is kind of
that I would say critical move in the
opening that where it gets its name is
this wasn't played for a long time and
then all of a sudden someone kind of
noticed that hey if I could play Knight
here to b8 then I could push forward
with pawn to c5 start to really push on
the Queen side of the board then I can
swing my knight over here to d7 try to
protect the square here on e5 so this
gives me a lot of options and right now
since it is the closed by Lopez we
didn't see any exchange or anything
going on then really just maneuvering
your Knights to where you want to go as
usually
good strategy so we don't see it very
often is always entertaining to see how
these players approaching if they go
with the main line or if they come up
with something super creative that we
haven't seen before from here why can
kind of choose between pawn to d3 which
is a little quieter or pawn to d4 which
is the main line continues with a pawn
to d4 Knight to d7 s we talked about
nicety to getting this involved they
can't come to c3 because of the pawn
bishop to b7 both sides just getting
their material developed a little bit
better Bishop down here c2 adding a
little pressure on the square here on e4
you can see both sides really just
getting all their minor pieces to
protect the center of the board rook to
e8 nice back here to f1 does want to
position it here to g3 if you could come
up here to f5 a nice little outpost also
wants to open up for this rook on a1 to
protect this pawn and then Bishop to f8
same sort of concept you do want your
work here on EA to protect the pawn but
does have to be aware that the dark
square bishop is not doing too much
right now maybe he could be in Quetta
with pawn to g6 in his bishop here to g7
or maybe outside the pawn chain with
Bishop to h6 so we had some options to
need to always keep in mind that when
you play with your vision back you know
that you need to eventually get it back
in the game or it's just kind of a
wasted piece on the board Knight to a g3
and then upon to g6 stopping the knight
come over here to f5 I'm not sure that I
necessarily like the pawn to g6 totally
understand why you would do it I think
there's an option to try another theory
Knight to b6 you know if he does play a
nice of e5 you can always kick it back
if you want to that's fine but starting
to put a little pressure on the Queen
side of the board I think this makes a
lot of sense but the main line is just
to play pawn to g6 both of these players
are spending about 10 seconds per moves
they're just going down the main line
doesn't seem like a lot of preparation
went into any crazy variations that are
outside the main line and so we continue
with just the main line pawn to a4 and
then
on the c5 looking to blow up the center
at the board and then pawn up to d5 now
if we come back a little bit earlier and
say you know when the night came down
here to you know f1 if white were to try
to play pawn to d5 at this point now
it's little trick is just pawn to c6
then we see exchange on board this is
not nearly as good White has lost a
central pawn here the LightSquared
Bishop is putting a lot of pressure on
white so it doesn't necessarily like
this but if we kind of move things
around and all of a sudden black pushes
forward with pawn to c5 now it makes
total sense for the pawn to come here to
d5 this is definitely a closed position
no one's trying to open up this game at
all and usually in a closed position
Knights are going to reign supreme so
you'll see a lot of maneuvering with the
Knights to get into the best positions
fine little outpost moves and then start
to attack some of these pend like the
backward pawns here on d6 so keep that
in mind as we're kind of going through
pawn down here c4 just solidifying the
pawn chain making a little more
difficult for some of the the squares to
move around or the pieces to move around
Bishop to b3 doesn't make it anymore or
d3 as well now the bishop to a g5 and
there were a couple options didn't have
to play Bishop to g5 could have been
stead decided to play you know is rook
get involved into the game you know that
makes sense maybe get as Queen involved
but decided to go and get his Bishop
here to g5 and then pawn to h6 and and
this is one of those where this is the
mainline pawn to h6 forcing the bishop
to move but I like a little bit
different line I like Queen to c7
starting to put more pressure on the
Queen side of the board this Knight is
no longer pinned down to the Queen so it
doesn't have to worry about that anymore
it's a bishop takes the knight that's
fine you can just recapture with the
knight right here the problem I have
with the main line is after pawn to h6
we see the bishop come back here Knight
down to c5 queen up here to d2 there is
both the Queen and the bishop attacking
the pawn and so the pawns almost forced
to come here to h5
and all of a sudden black is completely
weakened his King side of the board he
can defend this with proper you know
play throughout the rest of the game but
white really didn't have to give up too
much a black doesn't have a strong
advance on the Queen side of the board
because he was really just playing
around with his pawns over here on the H
pile so no I'm not sure I necessarily
like the mainline but don't know all the
preparation that went into it for
probably an ACOG wanna he seems familiar
enough he didn't spend tons of time
playing these moves but he does have a
weakened King side getting into the
middle game now that the pond is no
longer on h6 then white plays Bishop to
g5 just coming back to exactly where we
were which is kind of why I don't
necessarily like bringing the Ponte
chicks but that's fine Bishop to g7
another play that he could have played
instead of that Queen to c7 could have
just played Bishop here to g7 rook to f1
Queen down here to Steven c7 now he
plays it and this is the first variation
in the mainline and a lot of players
will always reach out and say you know
how are the grey masters what really
separates them one of the big things is
their minds or computers and they
memorize all these crazy variations they
didn't spend much time at all there was
both both players there's maybe one move
where they spent over a minute
but other than that all their moves were
just automatic because they were pretty
much all memorized they spent maybe 10
seconds on most of the moves so getting
into you know 21 moves getting into the
middle game there's no mistakes because
this is all theory they all know all the
lines and there's not really any
complications they're just kind of
waiting for their opponent to play
something that's novel Queen to c7 is
the first novel move so we continue
Bishop to h6 we do see a bishop coming
back here to h8 and this is this is now
that we're out of theory Fabiana Caruana
actually took about 30 minutes to play
this Bishop to h8 he was trying to
figure out you know how some other
options would go he would really like to
play something pawn to a4 I think part
of his 30-minute calculation is going
through the lines of the bishop takes
the King K takes and now Knight up to f5
and
it's kind of tricky you have one option
just upon taking this is the most
obvious queen to g5 the king coma stage
7 we see Queen take check for Sandman
King move back and then all of a sudden
the knight is going to fall here on f6
King sides completely destroyed gotten
back the material on board so that's not
going to be good if we come back and say
let's say the pawn does not take instead
the king is going to move King to g8 I
know other squares really good you start
getting into King to h8 or h7 any of
these and you can get a check but well
that's definitely to be worse because
you're just going to checkmate after
Queen to g7 but let's say King to g8 now
the Queen comes up here essentially
forced to take the nice and then we're
going to have the same song and dance as
we did before the night is going to fall
really bad position so Fabiano after a
lot of deliberation decides to go ahead
and play Bishop back here to AJ he could
have just taken the bishop and you know
there's merit to that getting some of
the pressure off the board I think a
yellow slob does have a pretty strong
attack going on the King sided board so
I usually favor just exchange of
material but decides to go and play
Bishop back here to h8 and then Knight
to g5 and then night to h7 you can see
black playing really really defensive
here having your bishop back here at age
8 and night to h7 is not really how you
draw it up too often but we do see an
exchange kind of crazy that we're 24
moves and we see our first piece or pawn
coming off the board
we usually a much much sooner than that
but after that we see Bishop come back
here to e3 Queen to e7 just centralizing
and then palm pushing forward to f4 had
a little quieter moves but decided to go
ahead and start to blow up since he has
a strong attack on the King side the
board he wants to go ahead and activate
his rook here on f1 once this file opens
up semi-open file he can take with this
rookie view once too he can swing his
heather brooke over here to f1 so he
does have some options but wants to be
as aggressive as possible against his
appointed it he knows right now is
playing very very defensive Fabiana
takes on f4 and then the bishop
recaptures
have also taken with his rook on f4 and
swung another broke over here to f1 but
the time to go and take with his Bishop
King to g8 now work to f3 getting ready
to double-barrel with his other rook on
f1 Bishop g7 rook to f1 as we talked
about and then Knight to a d7 I really
think because the next move from why
it's going to be Bishop to h6 so that
you can get as clean over here very
aggressive square for the Queen that's
going to activate the double rooks as
we've looked at on the square here on f7
I think he really wants to be playing
rook to f8 to control this square
otherwise this works not doing a ton you
know attacking this backward square
right here on e4 is not the tactic he
needs to be looking at because he's
eventually going to play Knight down
here to e5 that's going to be blocking
the rook anyway so I think Knight - f -
d7 not necessarily to move the he wants
to be playing but that's what if Bishop
h6 we do see the exchange on board and
then Queen to f8 and this is important
as far as the rook to the f8 is now a
mistake it's just that ship has sailed
because then Knight to h5 pawn can't
recapture it is going to be checkmate
rook to g3 only way to stop it
Queen down to g5 and then broke up here
that's going to be checkmate
so he had his opportunity to play rook
to f8 it is no longer there now Queen to
f8 can't just take you know this pawns
in the Queen's gonna fall that's
definitely going to be the bad way to go
but decided to bring his Queen back here
to d2 he has a strong attack does not
one to exchange his Queens off the board
night down to e5 and then rook to f6 so
you know putting so much pressure on his
opponent this light square bishop hasn't
been doing too much after that move of
pawn to d5 that kind of locked this side
of the board and so as long as he keeps
his pieces over here on the dark squares
this light square Bishop is not going to
be doing too much on the game he can
also later on activate his own light
square bishop he could play Bishop to d1
start to attack maybe even if he wanted
to sacrifice give us some crazy ending
where he hits ball vis rooks on the
Kings side that board sacrifices bishop
he does have that option as well rook to
d8 queen up here to g5
continuing his regression Queen to g7
Bishop down d1 as we talked about Bishop
c8 and then Queen down here to h4 King
f8 and just maneuvering a little bit
seeing where his opponent is going to go
black is completely on defensive can't
really do too much all of his pieces
just sitting back not many squares to go
to and some side could start to attack
on the Queen side of the board but once
you start using up some of your moves on
the Queen side of the board all of a
sudden your opponent can overwhelm you
on the King side so King to a g8 King to
h1 not really sure that the king is
under a ton of pressure here for white I
don't think he had to play King to h1
maybe now's the opportunity to just go
ahead and take on you know b5 and then
let's say pawn recaptures and then
Knight to e2 Queen g7 but now you play
Knight to d4 this is getting the knight
great square could attack this square on
b5 could come up here nice little
outpost on c6 start to really limit the
squares that the rooks can control he
can also play Knight to c6 that kind of
holds the you know this Bishop on c8
hostage because the pawn can't say
because it's being pinned down by the
rook so I think that was the move that
maybe he wanted to play Quinta h8 maybe
just a little bit too paranoid about an
attack from black but Fabiana was not
doing any attacking right now rook to e7
now the bishop takes on h5 and then the
pond recaptures and we look at and say
you know why did he not take with his
own pawns he really can't take because
then nice h5 and things start to get
pretty pretty bad if you know the bishop
were to take and then Queen to g7 ok
well now the pawn just takes pawn to
recapture and then the bishop just comes
back to you - do you want got that pawn
for free so all no no way to really stop
it decides to go and just take over on
the Queen side of the board yeah that
slop continues with Bishop to d1
attacking the pawn right here
and then Queen to g7 bishop up here
takes on a four queen day seven you can
kind of see that this Queen just doesn't
have too many great squares to go to is
kind of locked in is somewhat playing
defensive waiting to see where y'all
have to go in to play Queen to g5 pawn
to a5 pandey fogs not doing much of
anything just doesn't have any great
options King to g1 I don't think he
needs to be this defensive agin with his
King but maybe he doesn't want to have
to worry about something a bishop to to
b5 and then we see some crazy exchange
on board and then there's some
combination where he has a perpetual
check in this withdrawal I don't think
Fabiana could actually pull that off but
why just doesn't want to have to deal
with that right now so he plays King
here to g1 Queen back here to h8 rook
here to f4 getting ready to activate it
bring it over here to h4 that could be
very very deadly Queen to g7 rook to h4
Knight down here to d3 it's a nice
outpost but that's not really what the
games about right now but that's fine
not many great options rook here to h6
attacking now Knight comes back 'if I've
much better outpost move rook to f4
Bishop to d7 could exchange if he wants
to but decides to go ahead and play the
Queen back here to h4 getting ready to
push to h8 if he wants to does just open
up a ton of opportunities for him King
to a g8 that's kind of a forced move you
know he would have lost his Queen if he
didn't but the problem with that is now
his rook is going to fall Queen takes on
e7 rook to e8 the material advantage
just going in the wrong direction the
bishop does eventually take on a4 but
then after rook to f6 then Fabio decides
the now's the time to go ahead and
resign there's just too many threats on
board the knight can start to get
involved but he can get too many major
pieces on the King side of the board so
it recognizes his faith decides to go
ahead and resign so you know yeah a lot
of congratulations to him he was
completely outmatched from a
eating perspective but it was already
tied for second in a tournament playing
extremely well and now he's tied with
Wesley so for a first place so
congratulations to him played extremely
well against a variation that we don't
see all that often in the Rye Lopez but
he seemed prepared for it knew the main
line and then took it down a place where
he had a great attack and executed
better than Fabiano did so
congratulations thank you guys for
watching around 7:00 it's been one of
the best tournaments we've covered in a
while lots of lots of action players
really going for the win each and every
game so hopefully you guys are enjoying
it and we will see you tomorrow for
round 8